i didn't realize when i uh casually
mentioned
uh this monday and did a segment about
victimhood and cancel culture on tuesday
that this was going to continue blowing
up to the degree that it has we've
already talked about the dr
seuss fiasco earlier on in the show but
now we have
another republican who has found
another way to portray herself as the
victim
in a completely unhinged and ludicrous
way for the party of personal
responsibility the modern republican
party seems to have
no trouble whatsoever finding
other people to blame for just about
everything
i'm talking now about trumpian q anon
congresswoman
marjorie taylor green who gave a speech
yesterday
in the house of representatives where
she claimed that
when she has to wait in a line to go
through a metal detector to get into the
house chamber
that that is a form of voter suppression
now you're probably anticipating more of
an explanation from me about what she
means
there's no more this is what she said
take a listen to her
ranting and raving yesterday mr speaker
i rise in opposition to h.r one
while we're talking about voter
suppression in long lines
i'd like to point out that there's real
voter suppression that happens right
here in congress
many members of congress have to stand
in long lines to enter the chamber going
through metal detectors emptying our
pockets
and being treated very disrespectfully
so that is real voter suppression and
it's a shame that it happens right here
on the house floor
standing in line to vote is not voter
suppression is just part of the voting
process
just like people stand in line to buy
groceries at the grocery store
long lines to go through a metal
detector
to go into the house chamber is a form
of voter suppression
voter suppression and protecting
congress from someone
carrying a gun in the chamber are not
the same thing and in practice you know
the
the obvious question here would be you
know marjorie
to even plausibly accept what you're
saying
you would have to demonstrate that going
through the metal detector
has caused you or some of your
colleagues to miss
a vote in the house of representatives
and of course there's no evidence
anybody
has missed a vote thanks to having to
wait a few minutes in line now
to be fair she is one of the most
ignorant people in congress
so it wouldn't come as a huge shock that
she may not understand
the difference between voter suppression
and standing in line
for hours to vote and not even being
sure
if you'll be allowed because somebody
might have purged you from the voter
roll
there's that and then there's her
standing in line for a few minutes to
get into the house of representatives
as one of the most privileged
individuals in the united states
a member of a 1 out of 435 members of
the house
and having to just stand in line for a
few minutes there
and then she introduces this idea of
standing in line at the grocery store
and by the way if voting is like
going for groceries you can now get
groceries delivered
so why shouldn't you be able to get a
ballot delivered
which she's against but we'll skip that
layer of hypocrisy for today because
it's just another
rabbit hole one other thing though about
groceries
if marjorie taylor green did have to
stand in line for groceries for as long
as some people have to stand in line
to vote due to poll closures and
understaffing of polling places
you can be damn sure that marjorie
taylor greene
would be demanding congressional action
immediately
on grocery store lines there's no
question about it it just hasn't
affected her personally yet
now i guess the the sort of real
question here is
is marjorie taylor greene pretending not
to know the difference between these
things
and playing dumb for her ignorant
followers
or does she really not know i actually
can't tell anymore with these people
she also said that standing uh in line
at the house of representatives is voter
suppression
but standing in line to vote is not
voter suppression so like
even the arguments she's making are
uh internally conflicting it's a
complete and total mess she's a confused
individual painfully so and the crazy
thing is
her followers are even more confused
and they are the ones who fall for this
stuff and unless we make sure
that we again focus in on georgia in
2022 like we did in 2020
she may get herself re-elected um there
are there are concerns from republicans
that she may be facing a bloodbath
i would assume nothing trump if he's
able to raise money for that new pack
that he has that new grift
and uses the money to support marjory
taylor green because she supports him
she may well be able to get herself
reelected and one of the main signals
that i've been
looking to um one of the bellwethers i
will be looking to in 2022 to signal
what the future of trumpism
may be is whether the trumpiest of
trumpian elected officials marjorie
taylor greene madison cather and lauren
bobert and others
do they get reelected in 2022 if they do
and they may
it will signal that in all likelihood
trumpism has much more staying power
than many of us would like to believe